in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatments alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and with me the
studio today is dr. Fernando de Mille
he's a sports doctor here in Berlin
welcome dr. DiMaio to the show does it
surprise you that a 53 year old is in
better shape than a 20 year old it does
not surprise me a friend of mine he's at
the army and he's 63 years old and
sometimes the young troopers say that a
task is too long or too stressful or too
difficult and they cannot do that and he
shows them how to do it and he is by 40
years they are senior three times as old
as them but he's able to do that because
he kept his whole life exercising and
practicing and he has not lost a
physical ability and so he's fitter but
will he live longer I mean some studies
suggest that people who are living an
active life and that they put in years
onto the lives of longer it's difficult
to answer I know the studies but it is
not clear if people are fitted because
they are exercising and therefore living
longer off or if they are able to
exercise because they are they have a a
better place position if they are
healthier and it is difficult to make to
find the different if it's really
related to a longer life or to a higher
fitness okay the German sports
I mean specialist builder Holloman says
that people who are physically active
can remain 40 for 20 years that means
that when they are 60 they feel like a
40 year old is that really possible
it is indeed possible but it depends on
you if you keep on exercising if you
avoid unhealthy food and you have a
healthy lifestyle of course it's
possible I know a lot of people who are
fitter than younger people because they
keep to these healthy habits but why is
that what does physical activity really
do to the body that it can slow down
aging because many manifestations of
aging
not aging but are a loss of physical
activity because you are not using
certain functions you know if you don't
use it you lose it if you stop
exercising if you stop making
mathematics or if you stop playing
guitar you forget how to do it and you
are worse and exactly the same happens
with all physical abilities if you stop
exercising well you are going to see
that you are worse than before but that
is not necessarily related to aging but
to the lack of physical activity just
the lack of training but but when it
comes to disease like like heart disease
this disease and there's plenty of
evidence that exercising can prevent
heart disease and some say that it can
even prevent cancer is any truth to that
that is true and that is related to
heart disorders also to vascular
disorders coronary disorders for example
and also to cancer patients with breast
cancer or with a colon cancer they can
exercise and if they exercise the risk
of relapse of getting again a cancer is
lower but it had also been shown that
people who exercise regularly have a
lower risk of these forms of cancer and
therefore we can assume that exercise is
protecting them from cancer and is there
any medical or scientific evidence why
exercise can prevent from cancer no it
is not clear in some disorders for
example heart disorders it is clear
because heart is a muscle and what you
are doing by exercising is exactly the
same as you are doing with your arms or
with your legs you get more stronger
muscles exactly the same happens with
the heart but for other disorders
especially for cancer or for mental
disorders like Alzheimer it is not clear
why exercise is helping what is clear is
that exercise and physical activity to
help medicine has side effects
what about sportsmen exercise are they
any side effects and dangers some people
worry about it and think that they can
exaggerate and practice too much that
when we consider the huge problem of
lack of physical activity of the
conditioning for the whole population
not only in Germany but in the whole
world to think that it can be harmful
and that you can exaggerate well
that is not a real problem it's many of
my patients in my surgery my office say
that if there have any heart attack or
heart disease that they are very scared
to go for exercise but um exercise is
good for heart disease isn't it
it is indeed good and it has been shown
that it is better than sheer organ in
the surgical interventions and that you
can help patients faster and for a
longer time if they decide to exercise
than if they not if they don't we got a
viewer question from Russia golden
vasilieva from Russia has a father and
and her father had a heart attack and
now she wants to know how can she
motivate her father to go and put on his
sneakers and go for some sports well the
the best that he can do is to explain
him how it works and that exercise
indeed for him can be very helpful and
that is he is going to achieve a higher
physical performance a lower risk of
complications a longer life and that is
the best that he can do if he
understands it the motivation is going
to be there and he doesn't need an
external motivation he's going to have
his own to stay young healthy you need
to exercise and but how much exercise is
actually necessary for the positive
effect the recommendation
recommendations are worldwide the same
about two and half hours per week and
that means about 30-40 minutes daily of
exercise but what means exercise just
moving riding your bike or going for a
hike or just having an active lifestyle
and that is going to help at least 30
minutes when you feel you are really
doing something you are using your body
okay sure everybody should put this into
its gathering it's not that long time
and many other although it is indeed
yeah and let's get into some viewer
questions we got many of our viewers
like Helen Nephilim from Ghana and Mark
Young from Scotland want to know if
people have to go to the gym or to the
fitness studio or is just two and a half
hour walk is enough for younger people
it's not enough if you are 75 years old
you don't need you know necessarily need
a gym if you go for work daily if you
have a dog for example or if you use
your bike to move around it is
enough but younger people need more
exercise because they have a higher
physical level they just need more than
that but the most important aspect is do
what you like if you don't like running
for example then try swimming if you
don't like rowing well try aerobics in
the group that is the best source of
motivation to something that feels good
and that you like our view anuncio
Moretti from Italy is 50 years old and
he has a new girlfriend who likes
running and now his girlfriend wants to
take him for a run and is it okay for
him that's what he asked to start
running with 50 it's not only it is ok
it can also help him
I know a study with older people and it
they could show that he exercising for 3
months their physical performance was
twice as high as before the exercise
program and the most interesting aspect
of the study was that the younger
patient in the study was 85 years old
and that means that also very all people
can improve their physical performance
in a short time if they start exercising
therefore he could start jogging and he
is going to the surprise and his
girlfriend also so it's never too late
to start exercising its Neri motivating
things the doctor to mio for being with
us in the studio
enjoy our welcome
you